radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene is really living
up to her nickname Marjorie Trader green
lately what started with the suggestion
via Twitter that the country needs a
national divorce in which we split into
two countries a country of red States
and a country of blue States has not
been unilaterally denounced by The Wider
Republican party and actually seems to
be getting some support from Fox News
propagandist Sean Hannity we knew when
we saw that Trader green was trying to
push her way into being taken more
seriously by the Republican Party once
Republicans took control of the House of
Representatives and it seems as though
to some degree it is working so let's
look at the tweets that started it all
Marjorie Taylor green tweeting quote why
the left and right should consider a
national divorce not a civil war but a
legal agreement to separate our
ideological and political disagreements
by States while maintaining our legal
union definition of irreconcilable
differences inability to agree on most
things or unimportant things tragically
I think we the left and right have
reached irreconcilable differences I'll
speak for the right and say we are
absolutely disgusted and fed up with the
left cramming and forcing their ways on
us and our children with no respect for
our religion Faith Traditional Values
and economic and government policy
beliefs so she goes on to explain more
and to make this case on Twitter that we
need a national divorce she then
appeared yesterday on the Sean Hannity
program Sean Hannity is a Fox News
propagandist and she said I don't want
to see Civil War
but that's the direction that things are
going
and here's my question you know how did
you get to this this
point I mean I look at topics for
example how do you reconcile defund the
police and no bail laws with Law and
Order how do you reconcile secure
borders and wide open borders how do you
well the way you reconcile it is
nobody's serious on the left is saying
that the police should be defunded and
I've not seen anyone argue for open
borders you reconcile it by realizing
that you're lying
reconcile energy independence with
energy dependence and new green dealism
how do you reconcile peace through
strength uh with with people that want
to gut our defense you know there I
don't see middle ground on a lot of
these issues so what is the other answer
if it's not a divorce
so look at that Hannity saying the
divorce is the natural way to go
well exactly Sean that's the problem and
where we are today and in in my life in
my world I all of my friends are regular
Americans everyone I talk to is sick and
tired and fed up of being bullied by the
left abused by the left and disrespected
by the left and our ideas our policies
our ways of life have become so far
apart that it's just coming to that
point and the last thing I ever want to
see in America is a civil war no one
wants that at least everyone I know
would never want that right but it's
going that direction and we have to do
something about it wow
wow now there are so many different
directions that we could go with this
idea
um but the most important thing to
understand which makes the entire idea
Dead on Arrival
for them is that the blue State country
if we were to divide up so to speak the
blue State country would be fine
the red State country would not be
viable
because these folks they don't like to
admit it but look at the data blue
States regularly outperform red States
in terms of GDP per capita now a lot of
people say well the blue states have
higher GDP because they have more
population well but look at it per
capita okay the blue States would end up
being quite a wealthy country the red
States as a country not so much blue
states have more diverse economies blue
States aren't as reliant on any one
industry or sector red States on average
are extraordinarily reliant on one
Industry Texas overwhelmingly is an oil
state
Kansas overwhelmingly an Agriculture
state this makes their the red State
economies significantly less Dynamic and
dramatically more vulnerable to one
industry fluctuating blue States tend to
have more educated workforces which
leads to higher paying jobs more
Innovation and larger tax revenues with
which to do things the larger tax
revenues have left blue states with
dramatically better infrastructure than
red states which makes it easier for
businesses to go to the blue States and
for goods to be transported between and
out of and Into the Blue States so
that's where the businesses are going to
continue going you look at education
dramatically better in blue States you
look at Health Care dramatically better
in blue States so when you look at all
that
that alone should make you question
could a red State country even survive
but then look at the the maybe one of
the most important things
you look at Federal subsidies red states
are disproportionately reliant on
federal subsidies States like
Mississippi Kentucky and others who
receive so much more money from the
federal government than they contribute
on the other hand you have so many blue
states that are over contributing in
order to subsidize those red States so
if you separate that and say well now
we've only got I guess some some red
state federal government
economically and financially it doesn't
make sense so you can talk about is this
possible is this legal can States
unilaterally secede or whatever you know
all these different conversations
they're asking for something that would
not be a viable country because of the
realities of blue and red States one
other by the way unconstitutional thing
that was suggested during this Marjorie
Taylor green wants if you move from a
red state to from a blue state to a red
State because the blue states are so
terrible despite all the indicators
being better
um you don't get to vote right away
which by the way is not the way the law
Works explaining why she thinks this is
a good idea green is saying that a
national divorce would Empower
individual states to form a smaller
government reduce the federal debt set
their own environmental standards and
the congresswoman has another idea as
well Banning people who move from Blue
states to Red States from voting for
five years so they don't bring their bad
politics with them I actually favor that
idea he likes it okay completely illegal
doesn't make any sense can't do it
couldn't do it would never pass
unconstitutional it makes makes no sense
whatsoever so two parts to this three
parts to this Marjorie Taylor green
support something that is outrageous
number two the entire thing actually
wouldn't work blue States would be fine
red States would fail and number three
it's actually getting some support from
people as visible as Fox News propaganda
Sean Hannity very scary stuff
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below